[Music]
so halloween kills is a sequel to the
2018 halloween movie just called
halloween that's actually a sequel to
halloween that retconned all the
halloween sequels before it so following
the events of the 2018 halloween movie
halloween kills follows lori strode's
acquaintance played by anthony michael
hall everyone finds out michael myers is
still out there so he's like all right
let's get a mob together cause mob
mentality why have freddy krueger go
after michael myers when you can have
dunning-kruger
much more dangerous and usually i start
out with like oh what i liked about the
movie what i liked about this movie were
the concepts that didn't actually stick
the landing to like i appreciate that
the movie has a lesson to give about mob
mentality and the dangers of fear not
the first movie on earth to do that by a
long shot but i appreciate the attempt
that said it is a bummer that it came
across really pretentious like this
movie was so far up its own [ __ ] ass
what's lori strode gonna do in this
movie wins in pain in the hospital and
then give a monologue at the end that's
what she does it's a classic case if
they built the marketing around that
character and that character just gets
sidelined for someone else and i'm not
even looking for a great halloween movie
just at least a fun one even the bad
halloween movies i can still have fun
with because for the most part they lean
into what they are and they own it there
was no such leaning here this movie did
not know this movie was like
that head chef or restaurant owner in
kitchen nightmares you ever watch
kitchen nightmares i love kitchen
nightmares just easy casual watching for
me anyhow halloween kills is like a head
chef or a restaurant owner in kitchen
nightmares where they're like this is
the best meal you're gonna find on the
coast we're five-star cuisine it's like
you're not
and you don't know you're not and that's
the problem this movie took itself way
too seriously to actually be a fun
slasher halloween movie but then i got
mixed signals as to whether or not it's
taken itself seriously at all like there
are moments where it's like you have
this heavy moment
example there's this heavy moment about
mob mentality and then this mentally ill
patient throws himself off this roof and
splats on the ground and you see their
busted up brain like brain just outside
the skull you see their body just on the
ground i was like
you can't mix that kind of gore with a
heavy moment like that with a message
like that i suppose you can
but this movie didn't do it well and
speaking of the gore and halloween kills
the gore
felt gratuitous you know there was no
style to the killings this is the kind
of gore you throw on screen because
you're trying to hide the fact that you
can't come up with a creative kill in
your movie and that's what halloween
kills comes across as just a complete
lack of creativity and trying to hide it
under the guise of like no no we have a
message and it's a good one oh that's
not landing here's a bunch of blood
where's the 2018 halloween movie i felt
was creative and it did justify its own
existence and justified the retcon that
it did this movie
does what you might fear it does which
is have a severe case of sequelitis in
the sense that the 2018 halloween was
probably supposed to be the one and done
thing and it was well received and they
were like well i guess we should make
another one but at that point whereas
the previous halloween movie was
inspired this movie just doesn't know
where to go feels like it chases its own
tale and concentrates on all the wrong
people and all the wrong characters
sorry but laurie strode and michael
myers kind of a thing with this
iteration with this interpretation of
halloween i get that it was random
chance that threw them together in the
first place in the last movie it was the
weird doctor guy that threw them
together again but point is they are
thrown together now and you can't have
jamie lee curtis back as lori strode
just to have her be like all right just
sit in the hospital and
do not much and since you see it in the
trailers i suppose i'll talk about it at
that scene where karen takes michael
meyer's mask didn't like that they did
that you never get a real clear shot of
michael myers but you see more than you
probably should see for longer than you
should see it being michael myers and
then in the end of this movie no
spoilers but i will say there's just
zero payoff
i just left the movie theater going
sweet i sat through all of that for no
payoff so i'm going home and i guess i'm
gonna talk about this movie
what a bore fest and that's the real
metric right there it's like every
october there are movies that i watch
halloween movies that i watch from dusk
till dawn halloween the 2018 halloween
movie i haven't had a lot of time with
it but i've ended up watching it in the
subsequent october since its release but
this isn't it i can't see myself
watching this every year in fact i can't
see myself remembering this in t-minus
one day yeah i've already forgot
dammit what a bummer all right so
halloween kills my hope for future
halloween movies have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know or
what's your favorite halloween sequel
you know maybe the halloween sequel that
people hate on you're like yeah but i
like it again whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you